well there are so many layers to both of
your characters which i really love i
mean neither one of them is who they
seem on the surface
so
karen how did you find your inner loop
what to find her for you it's a great
question i think that to me
the
the key to understanding and unlocking
lou
was was sort of about understanding her
past and
i think that at the end of the day
what lou
wants
um
and wanted in the show
was love and
was to be seen and understood she
obviously lost her mother and and
probably had more traumas that we don't
even
know about but instead of approaching
you know the quest for love and being
understood in a way that was uh
kind and grounded she she went to great
lengths and sort of disguised her wants
with wanting power
and
and
aggression and doing anything she could
to to rise to the top so so for me she's
her her motives were always
um
rooted in just like wanting to be seen
and wanting to be
uh
known and and and and loved and secure
and wanting all these things in her life
that she never felt like she had and i
think she's probably reached a point
where she's she's just doing anything to
get there so so like a reckless sense of
ambition and also just nothing to lose i
think when you have nothing to lose and
i think she had really nothing um
you will go to great lengths and she
obviously
um
went to too great of lengths but but
her having nothing to lose and
everything to gain was really the most
inspiring kind of driving part of the
performance for me
van how did your channel join us was
there something about her wardrobe or
her environment that would help you get
into her mindset once you've got on set
um well i know i mean i the wardrobe is
just part of her job i think in a way
but um i think the
the idea being that she is a very much
go get it girl you know gone through
through great lengths to be where she's
at
and what it took to get her there right
and how to not give that up be in
control take control of the situation no
matter what um and then the rest of you
know
i i channeled
myself other women that i know
you know who who are in their 40s and
who have had life where they chose their
careers for a very long time and have
pushed back their
family home and the struggles that they
encounter and you know the more
outrageous i was at work
the the more those vulnerable sides at
home paid off you know
what you guys most enjoy about working
with each other on this spending time
together having each other to experience
this with it sounds like
you were fans of each other's work going
into this so what's it like to get to
work and share scenes with an actor that
you really admire it's great
makes it easy
it makes it easy it makes it more
enriching and i mean
for me there's so many really exciting
parts of this job like it really is
such a dream to be able to do this uh
professionally
but one of the one of the joys of of
this this line of work if you're lucky
is working
across from people that you admire and
and and are fans of and it's just like
diane is so wonderful in this role and
the rest of the cast too is just
incredible and to see everyone show up
to work every day
and just slip into their
you know roles perfectly it was really
inspiring i mean i think when everyone
kind of has it so locked in you can't
help but want to go the extra mile and
this this whole cast just made so much
sense
and it really was like very fun to play
with with everyone with diane with
thomas decker like erica alexander i
mean so many
amazing performances in this
there are really interesting
contradictions to joyce i mean clearly
redmond has tortured her in a way that
he should have to answer for but instead
she sort of has her own harem of men
that she essentially tortures
what was it like to have all those
different guys to work with did you have
any particularly fun moments with any of
them from finn to thomas to ross i mean
you had quite
quite a group thing
we've had a lot of fun moments you know
i
torturing someone on camera is
definitely fun to do
you know but i i've always tried to
she's not cruel just to be cruel right
to her it's truly about being ahead of
the game and being a perfectionist
because she is right so she expects that
level of
perfection from her assistance which is
why she likes lou because she feels like
oh finally there's somebody who will do
what it takes right
um so and then
i mean i just feel
bad for uh gerardo who plays my husband
because he in a way to me he gets the
most abused right like
here he is
adonis coming out of the water naked
doesn't get as much as a glance from his
own wife you know that that love scene
we have trying to conceive
is probably one of the most unsexy
scenes i have ever
witnessed witnessed and had to play and
you know so i i felt i felt for his
character as well by the end of these
episodes it feels like there is still
more story to tell would you like to
keep exploring the story have you had
conversations about a possible second
season and what that could be
i mean we have not i mean i've not had
i've not had a convo and i'm not opposed
either i think it kind of depends on
when it comes out and how people receive
it and if i mean
there's so many there's so many
different routes that we could go i mean
i'm just trying to think of what you
would say or what what's what's left of
i
blew kind of came in like a wrecking
ball
um and i don't i don't know what's
what's left to explore but if there's
something if kathleen's down i'm down
yeah it certainly seems like this is a
an interesting dynamic that uh would
never get old so yeah yeah
thank you guys so much thank you so much
i'm really excited for performances
thank you so much